[Music]
e
for
[Music]
the bacteria needed basilis subus
naturally exists in nature and more
specifically in rice straw in fact
that's how natto used to be made but
today when companies are making Nat the
fermentation bacteria is added to cooked
soybeans so atuya decided that he wanted
to try making Nat the oldfashioned way
using
[Music]
straw
so they grow their own straw and they
take that straw wrap the soybeans and
allow them to ferment naturally and what
you end up with is this sticky slimy
pungent Japanese delicacy that
apparently tastes
amazing I'm honestly intrigued but the
one thing that atsuya wasn't really able
to do was explain what Nat tastes like
so I asked my friend Remy from Tokyo
Japan to give me a recipe to try to cook
and that's what I'm going to do the
toast I want to talk to you about today
is Nat Tam toast you need one slice of
toast one pack of natto mix it in with
all the condiments that it comes with
one hard boiled egg chopped parsley a
little bit of mayo and pinch of salt and
pepper so for those who that has never
had Nat before um all I could say is
it's a fermented soybean it's served any
time of day in Japan the flavor of the
NAT is hard to describe it's Savory mild
Savory with a soy sauce flavor with a
hint of bitterness a lot of people who
try not though gets put off because the
first thing they see is how slimy it is
and the aroma it gives off isn't
Pleasant it is definitely an acquired
taste the reason why I like this toast
is because the flavor of n Nat and the
egg is just so harmonious to me and I
guess the a little bit of mayo just tops
It Off and plus it's kind of a comfort
food and easy food for me to make when
I'm lazy it's a qu essential food in
Japan the egg with the toast it kind of
gives natto another chance because the
egg kind of counter offs the smell of
the natto but definitely the sliminess
is there so I hope you try it out and
enjoy before I try Remy's dish I'm just
going to try the nto on its
own okay
the flavor is not that strong honestly I
feel like it just has this very earthy
flavor to it but it's the kind of that
sliminess that's around it that just
immediately coats your entire like
throat and mouth even my
lips are like kind of sticking
[Music]
together ooh it's like it almost makes
me feel like I put on lip gloss after I
bite into it it's not as if having the
egg salad and the bread counteract all
of the side things from the nut though
it just kind of helps tone down I think
some of the flavor of
[Music]
it it's definitely a a texture thing to
get used to this nut though was easy to
find just at my local Japanese grocery
store obviously it's not made the way
atuya makes it the kind of oldfashioned
way with the rice grain but I still was
able to give this a go which I think is
worth it am I finishing this experience
loving not though not necessarily but I
enjoyed the process of trying it and I'm
really happy that I did this is the
third time that we've really looked at
an ingredient that might be a little bit
misunderstood and learned about it from
within that culture the first was about
blood pancakes the second was fermented
Mar's milk and now these soybeans I'd
love to know if there are any other
foods that you'd like to see us explore
leave a comment until then enjoy your me
s